nella vita ragazzi ci sono dei pericoli
ci sono pericoli che molti di voi non
[Musica]
riescono a comprendere magari perché non
ci avete mai pensato tanto nella vita
faccio attenzione a tante cose e oggi
sono qua per provare a trasmettermi per
un po di vale chiamiamoli consigli per
cercare di evitare di mettersi in brutte
situazioni perché qua si rischia la vita
ragazzi sono cose molto molto importanti
che molti sottovalutano ok quindi io ho
il potere di parlare a tante persone e
quindi alle volte mi mi rendo conto di
dover fare un determinato tipo di
discorso come in questo caso siamo su
rombo fair slot voi conoscete gli
aspiratori quelli che servono per
aspirare le briciole in casa con gli
automatici che vanno in giro
ecco sono il male ecco il suono già dice
tutto però ve lo mostriamo sul rombo
first blood c'è un tasto che si chiama
asac un tasto per succhiare ok un tasto
per l'uso a e per andare alle 20 poi
sprintare e poi home care che non so
cosa voglia dire a lui sta tentando di
uccidermi va bene aiuto questo fare non
ho capito il set
cosa devo fare qui
[Musica]
oh mio dio ha sbattuto contro il muro
via via viaria cosa devo fare io possa
creare le robe tipo far cadere
lampadario in testa al tizio che odio
che lo sta trascinando aiuto io possa
chiare le robe ma sto male sta scappando
dalla finestra dove dove la gente non la
vedo ragazzi stanno scappando ma non so
bene da dove
ecco lo aspetta che c'era l'altro
lampadario ok perfetto no
occhio
beric madonna che testata non ho capito
il televisore come faccio a dichiararlo
però serve per attirare la gente
previsore ok ci siamo ragazzi era il
frigo occhio apriti si è fissato aiuto
ce la macchinetta del caffè occhio
patrona che male si è corso sul coltello
lo zio parte c'è madonna ma cosa
facevate così tanti soldi in casa ma
possibile tra l'altro non ho mai visto
un coso un affare di questi che pratiche
che c'è il clacson mai colpito
tranquilli ragazzi tanto non andranno
mai via da una strada c'era sicuro io
c'è anche l'altro e di lampadario zio
non so quanto convenga passati quattro
no averlo colpito lo stesso va bene c'è
ancora ci sono ancora le finestre che me
ne sono tirati addosso non sapevo
neanche aia aiuto vieni quasi a vico sa
sempre cosa
ok a bari good manca fully charge età
posso picchiare la gente ok va bene
aiuto ai audio che cos'è ronaldo sto
tizio questo com'è possibile
sta per esplodere il condizionatore
occhio a non esplode il condizionatore
se non solo per freezer la gente questo
cos'è quello serviva per risposto che è
morta una c'è una un ladro lo dire me lo
sono mangiato va bene io ve l'ho detto
che sì così qua sono il male ragazzi poi
fate voi
direi di dare un'occhiata anche a sto a
fare qua che potrebbe essere l'incontro
giusto in questo momento
very good e sono adesso devo pulire la
casa ma come barone parola no ragazzi
non la posso pulire impossibile ma non
posso mai in un minuto
no ragazzi è possibile non posso pulire
casa in un minuto c'è troppo sangue per
terra senza nella parte polizia va bene
siete consapevoli del fatto che è
impossibile che io tolgo tutto lo schifo
la terra vero non ce la posso fare la
gara è troppo è troppo è troppo schifo
c'è troppo schifo per terra non lo posso
togliere tutto sono solo uno ne
servirebbero 26 di me per far fuori sta
roba
quanta roba c'è come 18 set ma come
potrei mai fare una roba del genere
spiega siamo neanche a 30 per cento
35 over va bene 40 per cento livello 2
completato ti danno anche il volto bola
bel gioco dell'anno adesso è ancora più
difficile perché le cose che rubano sono
tre va bene non ho neanche capito
laddove che stanno entrando
da ieri prove con quanti lo voglio so
cosa ok 1 entrato nella stanza da pranzo
che li stava da pranzo 1 entrato dalla
finestra di qua perfetto allora
innanzitutto iniziamo subito come fa a
rispondere sta roba qua perfetto e un
andato magari riesco a utilizzare
multiple trappole per più persone
credono cosa no non è vero non riesco
proprio che andiamo andiamo andiamo
andiamo andiamo a forza forse riesco a
colpire più persone con la stessa può
essere ok
sono qua vediamo se riesco a farlo fa
locale refolo cade giù dopo il ft non ha
colpito solo uno porca vacca c'è il
cammino che può esplodere va beh occhio
che va a fuoco benissimo questo non era
tra parte va beh madonna ragazzi sono
tutti e tre un casino sto facendo
ok venite di qua 20 qua vorrete no
troppo presto
avevano colpito uguale occhio agli
assoli castrato sono passati come così
che ho fatto a passare di qua c'e un bug
sono passato nell'altra stanza a caso va
bene c'è la finestra anche volendo e
ragazzi occhio vite quando la finestra
sempre ci aiuta
very good quello non so cosa servito ma
va bene anche questa finestra perfetto
mamma mia che soddisfazione mila sta
partita ragazzi tutti qua perfetto
calpestate vostro amico morto anche
quello ma dai
ecco quello li ha beccati tutti e due
fantastico ora se li faccio passare di
qua teoricamente non l'ho mancato aia
sono o sono morto no avevo fatto una
partita bellissima
l'ultima ragazzi e vediamo come non ne
sono sicuro però vabbè anche perché non
so ma entrano da qualsiasi finestra che
se questo ha regalato e vi devo attirare
un po perché se non li attirano gli
ammazzava venite tutti qua tutti tutti
tutti tutti tutti tutti da questa legge
ok adesso se riesco a fargli fare un bel
giro abbiamo qua molto bene
facce di questo very good
occhio sta diventando sempre più
difficile ragazzi dovrei riuscire a
raggrupparli per far saltare in aria sta
roba però non son riuscito a bere acqua
aspetto lampadario aspetto vetro
meraviglioso
[Musica]
di qua fuoco molto bene non la posso
fare risaltare la presa elettrica vero o
no purtroppo
fam ragazzi fantastico sono andata di
olivetta parte sono che sono belli
veloci devo trovare un modo per
rallentare un po di più è andato anche
questo ragazzi sto qua è forse un modo
per pulire casa buono e mentre gli
uccidi devi pulire casa è l'unico modo
che vedo proprio l'unica roba che vedo
oltre quello che già sto facendo marca
vacca no
ok
oddio io ho chiuso la porta in faccia
questa non lo sapevo si potesse fare
ok questo modo bagnato ok ma forse non è
che recuperi vita mangiando l'essere che
non ho capito come fai a dichiarare il
fuoco scusate non è elettrico sono qua
bene però sono morti tutti e ragga
teoricamente che ho fatta non manca
ancora poi come uno va come tanto quando
moglie lo lasciano le a notte sono morti
tutti quando muoiono lasciano le
bistecche
come è possibile
la cosa non l'ho capita arriviamo a 40
per cento di nuovo teoricamente stavolta
arrivano anche a 20 la musica del
titanic
poi c'è veramente meraviglioso
non arrivo non forza 20 ci arrivano 40
proprio impossibile poi tra l'altro gli
aspiratori non credo aspirino di al
sangue la vedo difficile
va bene bene ah sì che mi ricordo perché
ho iniziato a youtube per questo ragazzi
il vostro pulitore di fiducia ha fatto
la sua porca figura
anzi pulita
ci stava quello che viene vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi siete appena lasciato
il mi piace se video piaciuto ma chi vi
porta giochi così ma chi ve li porta se
non lo zio favi iscrivetevi schiacciate
la campanellina che rimanete aggiornati
i suoi video che escono apriamo un
canale per recensire aspirapolveri
ragazzi ci vediamo come sempre al
prossimo video e da ragazzi
[Musica]